the Joe Rogan experience the you know
the the war on drugs stuff it it's it's
increasingly going to be turned towards
China you know and in fact Trump has
been meeting with the Chinese president
and all the trade war stuff the
increasing the tariffs this is now tied
in to fentanyl and so supposedly in a
couple days this might be out by then
but there's this announcement of a new
partnership China says they're finally
going to crack down on these drug labs
hmm and we'll see if it happens but the
point is like we can do everything we
want to try to you know we can go to war
with China over this issue but you know
what is our past record in this realm
like the DEA helped kill Pablo Escobar
right but since then there's more
cocaine coming out of Colombia than
there ever was before you know nowadays
El Chapo was arrested tried that's doing
nothing to stop the drugs the cartels
the drugs coming into the US and and and
there's every indication that if we do
get China to stop this insane like 90
percent or more of the illicit fentanyl
comes from China that if we do get them
to crack down on it the industry is
going to go to India and India is
already starting to see these huge busts
like there's these Mexican cartel
members getting busted in India for
buying fentanyl in India yeah the thing
is like China and India have the the two
biggest chemical industries when it
comes to generics kind of low lower
level chemicals and pharmaceuticals the
US has the most profitable
pharmaceutical industry because we make
like the brand-name drugs things like
that but when you're talking about
generics and stuff like vitamin C
acetaminophen which is the drug in
Tylenol these are all made in China
place like India and so they have this
huge kind of brain trust of chemists you
know people go to university they they
not be chemists and then a certain
amount of them get into the illicit
industry right so Mexico doesn't have
that Mexico doesn't have its own
chemical industry and a bunch of
scientists who can make fentanyl who can
make these new drugs so so that makes
India so susceptible to it and and the
biggest problem is actually not even the
fentanyl itself it's the fentanyl
precursors and you know those are you
know the chemicals will be used to make
fentanyl exactly and so that was sort of
the main investigation in my book like
almost like 80 pages of the book are
dedicated to this one company they're
called yuan Chung
this Chinese company that makes more
fentanyl precursors than any company in
the world you know they they they're
legit and and not only that they sell
them to the Mexican cartels and they're
totally sanctioned not only sanctioned
by the Chinese government but they get
tax breaks from the Chinese government
they get subsidies they get their land
subsidized their staff training things
like that and that was sort of the most
jaw-dropping revelation that I had was
that the Chinese government is not only
failing to crack down but they're
encouraging this industry they're
encouraging the industry that's insane
so it's just the the idea is look it's
making a lot of money let's just keep
making money yeah it's a lot of people
asked me if they think this is a blatant
conspiracy to try to like inflict harm
upon the u.s. a subversive form of
warfare and so I think it didn't start
out that way I think that these these
benefits were given so that China could
increase its exports could grow its
economy particularly when it comes to
chemical exports so that's why these tax
credits started they're called
value-added tax rebates and so what that
means is any chemical that you use
- - any ingredients you use to make a
chemical for exports you can write off
the cost of those of those ingredients
when you export it so basically it's
like a sixteen percent tax rebate and so
they originally did that just to try to
like improve their economy improve their
exports but what's crazy to me now is
that last year in the middle of the
trade war this was at the height of when
you heard about the trade war every day
you know Trump was raising tariffs and
doing this and that right at the height
of that China increased the tax rebate
for fentanyl from 9% to 10% so it was
almost like a seems like a thumb in the
eye you know like for fentanyl you know
it's I don't know yeah it definitely
seems like a big [ __ ] you
[Applause]